Film Courage: This question is from viewer
Nolan Putnam “What is the most helpful habit
you’ve created (in regards to screenwriting)
that’s allowed you to become a professional?
Erik Bork, Screenwriter/Author: That’s a
great question, is there one habit that has
been the most helpful?
Probably we’ve talked about most of them,
probably the most important perspective has
been to see it as something I am always learning,
I’m always growing and that that’s okay.
It’s not like I’m supposed to know it
all and be perfect at it and the things that
I write are going to be great automatically
and others are going to love them.
To see it more as it’s an ongoing quest
of kind of a self-development, self-education,
I’m learning with everything that I write
what works better and not as good so it’s
like this journey of development that you
sort of like are going to enjoy the journey
as opposed to I have to get to a certain place
which it’s easy to feel that way because
the world works that way where I have to get
the agent, I have to get the sale, I have
to get something produced, I have to raise
my money and make my movie.
Like there are all these goals that we might
have in the world and a lot of times they
are out of our control and if you focus only
on those goals like what I can get, what I
can achieve instead of what can I express?
How can I just do what I decide I want to
do which is be a writer and keep learning
and growing and find some satisfaction in
that journey.
Because when you turn it into there have to
be these quantifiable results in terms of
money or others reactions, whatever.
Then you’re putting your power in this thing
that may or may not ever happen, you can’t
for sure make happen no matter what you do.
So I think that attitude might seem counterproductive
because Well to be successful (professional)
you want to focus on the professional goals,
right?
Well you do to some extent you are open to
feedback and you are educating yourself.
I didn’t say just go in a hole and do what
you want to do and never…and shut the outside
world out.
I’m saying engage with the world with feedback,
with education, with trying to understand
and get better so it’s growth but making
it a positive growth for yourself is about
making me better and making my writing better,
not making my results better.
Because when you focus on how do I give more,
how do I write something that is really going
to impact people more, how do I that?
How do I figure out how to do it?
How do I get better at it, you are then about
giving to other people and you will achieve
success I believe more when you succeed at
giving more.
You get more automatically as opposed to how
do I get the success, how do I get the breaks,
how do I get the right person to read it,
how do I get people to like it?
It’s more how do I create something so wonderful
that people will just automatically like it,
I’m not even concerning myself with that.
So it’s like taking the power into your
own hands and being about how you can improve
your stuff, your self as a writer, having
that approach I think is a stronger healthier
approach that is going to lead to success
more then you do it the other way.
Film Courage: That’s amazing because especially
to if you do live here in Los Angeles (I know
you said you don’t necessarily have to but
it definitely helps) you are bombarded every
second with reminders whether it’s billboards
or someone going by you, somebody else that’s
is higher up on the proverbial food chain
and it’s thrown in our face.
It’s really wonderful to think of the unplugging
from that because this is almost the anti-culture
here.
Was this something that was almost part of
your make-up or you had to learn this?
Erik: Oh no, I had to learn.
Again it’s like an everyday practice (that
thing again), an everyday practice of I’m
being about the purity of expression of growth
and learning and improving as opposed to as
opposed to how do I get the results that I
want from others.
Because we don’t naturally do it that way,
we have to sort of like decide that’s how
I’m going to approach this instead.
Film Courage: And also to in the last few
years (and not to get too morbid) but we’ve
seen people who have achieved tremendous success
obviously not be happy and then you have to
ask yourself well why am I doing this?
And it has to be (and as follow your bliss
bumper sticker on the back as it sounds) it
has to be about that because we do see these
people who have achieved these amazing results
and the end result for them showed that it
wasn’t enough.
Erik: I do think it really is about making
the daily practice/journey/writing whatever
enjoyable.
Being at peace and enjoying what you’re
doing each day, finding a way to make it that
way so the journey is a positive journey and
not be so caught up in the destination because
if you enjoy what you’re doing you’re
going to do it more, you are going to do it
better, you are going to want to learn more.
But it comes from a certain level of confidence
and trust that what you are doing is worthwhile
and if you measure that in only money or career
statistics you may never get there and you
may always be insecure about that.
The people who want to write, there is usually
more of a compassion, more of a purity of
I just want to do this for some reason.
So if you can really hold to that as opposed
to what the results are is what matters so
much you would probably have a better time
doing it, you will be happier, you’ll be
more productive and prolific and the results
usually actually follow from that.
Film Courage: Before you chose your major
for film and television what was your goal
or major before this?
Erik: What I first started college, I experimented
with being an English major and thinking about
writing fiction, poetry.
I experimented with being a music major briefly
but I pretty quickly took some introductory
film classes and I realized that this was
the medium that I wanted to try to write for.
Film Courage: And you’ve said that [film]
festivals really aren’t about the laurels
(I heard you say this in another interview).
I think that’s actually beautifully put.
Erik: I don’t think I said it but that’s
probably true.
Film Courage: Okay, let’s say you didn’t
say it but this goes back to what we’re
talking about, the end result is not what
it should be about.
And I know it’s easy to theorize that and
say these things and then you have to live
in a reality that is life and you’re competing
with people all the time and that’s something
that happens in pre-school and it happens
in adult hood but to really have something
that we get from it that is more than an accolade.
Do you think that is what keeps you going
in terms of why you do it?
Erik: I’m not sure what keeps me going to
be honest.
I think like I keep going like most writers
because that’s just what I do.
It’s what I’ve decided I do.
It’s what I want to do and I’m engaged
with the challenge of getting better and writing
things that really fulfill why I wanted to
be a writer.
They are the kind of things that I love that
I wanted to create more of in the world.
And I guess part of that is to get it out
in the world I’m going to need other people
to help me do that and finance it or whatever.
But it’s kind of like I haven’t achieved
yet what I wanted to achieve even though I’ve
worked on some big things and won awards and
made a living as a writer and stuff, there’s
a lot of kind of projects that I always got
into this because I wanted to do, that I still
want to do those.
So I think there is just a desire to create
and express that never seems to really go
away and so it’s just a chosen field.
It keeps me going because it’s just the
path that I’m on and have chosen and have
no reason to un-choose .
Film Courage: I can say the same for Film
Courage.
It would be great to have videos get this
[certain] amount of views but at the end of
the day it has to be about conversations (like
today’s conversation) and that’s worth
it for us.
That’s why we do this for.
So even though I’m not a screenwriter, there
has to be something else besides hoping Erik’s
video gets millions of views.
It has to be that the process was enjoyable
which it has been.
Erik: Thank you.
For me as well.
Film Courage: This is a great way to end.